Can we have the next question for
brother on my right?
I am Draj. I'm a meological engineer.
I'm working as a senior manager in
tractor and form equipment.
Dear brothers and sisters, today is an
excellent evening. I can say is a really
an eye opener to all Hindus
[Applause]
and I was really amazed astonished
surprised and whatn not about the
illustrations given by Dr. Zakir from
various Vedas
I have to admit and most of the people
here also will admit it's really a God's
gift given to Dr. Zakir.
One thing I could notice here is the
specification is very clear in Islam for
the human being to be followed in
Hindus. is not clear. Is there is not
clear.
Lot of misinterpretations are there. Lot
of interpretations and opinions, beliefs
is based on there. It is there but in a
different format. My request to the
organization is to call Hindu scholars
and Hindus and arrange for a debate so
that truth will come to surface.
[Applause]
so that Hindus and Muslims can become
much closer and closer
and be together
to to be together towards the prosperity
and unity and peace for the nation and
society. Thank you. Thank you.
The brother has given a very good
suggestion and I appreciate him. I do
agree with him. It's eye opener for many
of the Hindus even for the Muslims. It's
an eye opener even for the Muslims
brother. I'm sure is it or not
and the brother has given a very good
suggestion that we should call the Hindu
scholars and have a debate I would say
rather a dialogue and that is again
based on the verse of the Quran which I
started my talk with Surah Alah Iran
chapter 3:64 which says
come to common terms as we assign you
and that's what I'm doing brother I'm
traveling different parts of India
different parts of the world having
dialogues with scholars of Christianity
of Hinduism I'm only a student I'm not a
scholar. I'm a student of comparative
religion and I have had discussion
dialogues in Kerala with Hindu priest in
Bombay and now there's a request
inshallah I'll be going to Bangalore
very shortly within a couple of months
that Shishi Ravi Shankar
he has requested we should have a common
dialogue
and you might have heard of the person
Shishi Ravi Shankr he's of great fame he
has got centers in 40 different
countries of true living and if anyone
in Madras if you can organize together
if there's any priest in madras we would
love to have to come on a common
platform and have a dialogue
[Applause]
I was there in madras and I spoke with
shankarachari of kashi when I'd come
last time a few months back and we had a
discussion on the issue of barbari
mazjid asking some questions and gave
him some clarification of kashi and
there's no problem brother we love it we
are here to come to common terms if you
can arrange or any brothers out here
non-muslim or muslim brothers can
arrange any dialogue just come to come
and understanding but get a person who's
knowledgeable you know knowledgeable of
high standard whether Shankarachara or
top priest so that we can discuss and
come to common terms live harmoniously
build a big Indian nation
do we have a question from a non-Muslim
sister exactly question from a
non-Muslim friend of mine uh she is
asking me like uh within You Muslims
itself you have confusion like uh when
you meet you ask first the question is
uh whether you're a Wahhabi or
Sunni whatever this kind of questions
there's a confusion between you itself
what do you want us to follow what is
that uh we can exactly come follow and
uh the sister asked a question that the
non-Muslim sister asked there's a
confusion among the Muslim when you meet
you ask you are a wahhabi or are you hi
you are a sha you are a maliki so
there's a confusion amongst the Muslims.
So what's the reply? I do agree with the
non-Muslim sister that unfortunately
many Muslims call different names. But
when I tell the Hindus to go back to the
Vedas, I tell the Muslims to go back to
the Quran.
Allah says in the Quran in Imran chapter
number three verse number 103 Allah says
hold the rope of Allah strongly and be
not divided. We have to hold to the robe
of Allah. The robe of Allah is the
glorious Quran and the authentic hadith.
Allah says in the Quran in surah chapter
number 6 verse number 159 that anyone
who makes division in the religion of
Islam. Oh prophet you have nothing to do
with him. Making sex making division in
Islam is prohibited. It is haram. But
when we ask the Muslims what are you?
Some say I'm Hanfi. Some say I'm a
Shafi. Some say I'm humbly. Some say I'm
a Salafi. What was the prophet? Was the
prophet Hanfi? Was he Shafi? Was he
humbly? Was he Maliki? What was he?
He was a Muslim. Allah says in the Quran
in surah Imran chapter number 3 verse
number 52 is Alisam Jesus Christ peace
be upon him was a Muslim. Allah says in
the Quran in surah Imran 3:67 that
Abraham peace be upon him he was a
Muslim. Allah says in the Quran in surah
chapter number 41 verse number 33.
Who is better in speech than one who
invites the way of thy lord walks
righteousness and says that I'm a
Muslim? Our beloved prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was a Muslim.
Allah has told us to call ourel Muslim.
They cannot be a better label than
Muslim. See all these four great Imas,
Imam Abu Hanifh, Imam Shafi, Imam A M A
M A M A M A M A M A M A M A M A Madbar,
Imam Malik, may Allah be pleased with
them all. They were great scholars. I
love them. I respect them all. They were
great scholars. But all these great
scholars said all these pro said that if
you find any of my fatwa which goes
against Allah and his rasool then you
throw my fatwa on the wall.
So here if you analyze that all these
imam that came they came not to make a
new sex they came for the people to go
back to the original scripture the Quran
that's a hadith. So what we have to
realize that I know there are people who
say that is in their hadith in which the
prophet said there will be 73 sex it's
hadith of a say hadith number 171 the
prophet said there will be 73 sex
prophet didn't say you should make
prophet knew that even though Allah says
don't make a bound to make so the best
is to go back to Allah and his rasool
and the best label you can have is call
yourself a Muslim any scholar let it be
anyone in the world let him be the
biggest scholar of the world you ask him
for proof
Produce your proof if you're truthful.
If you're honest, produce your proof. So
any scholar is the difference of
opinion. You ask him for proof. Get the
proof. Check it up. Therefore, in my
talk, I always give references. What I
say, what Zakir says is rubbish in
Islam. It is zero. Nil. Therefore, I say
zakir doesn't say Allah says
Allah one and only. If zakir says it is
rubbish, zero, nil in Islam. If Allah
says it carries weight, if the prophet
says it carries weight. So therefore,
sisters, Muslims should not be divided.
We should call ourselves Muslims and
follow the Quran and the Sai had anyone
who divides the religion, they're going
against the Quran.
Yes, brother. Can you close your Dr.
Mahadeva practicing medical practitioner
day before yesterday I attended Mr.
Abdul Rahim Green's lecture. There was a
question posed to him uh by a medical
student.
She asked about
paradise. Those who practice
Islam go to paradise and the rest of the
people go to the hell. Is it the answer
given by Mr. Abdim was not convincing?
Can you please explain? Thank you
brother. as a question somebody asked
brother Abdul Rahim Green that those who
practice Islam will go to paradise those
who don't practice Islam will go to hell
the answer wasn't convincing I was in
there I'm sure brother Abdra green may
have given a very convincing reply maybe
you didn't understand certain of his
points I know him he's a very good
speaker mashallah but regarding the
reply that will Muslims go to Jenna and
non-Muslims go to hell brother the
requirement go to Jenna is given in
surah als chapter 103 verse number 1 to3
it says
By the token of time, man is very in a
state of loss. Except those who have
faith, those who have righteous deed,
those who exalt people to truth that is
to dawa and those who exalt people to
patience and perseverance. The
requirement for any human being to go to
Jenna is four things. Iman, faith, what
I discussed of iman, righteous deed,
exorting people to truth and exorting
people to patience and pursue. If any
one of these four is missing under
normal circumstances, you shall not go
to Jenna. Only by calling yourself
Abdullah, Muhammad, Sultan, Zakir will
not take you to Jenna. Just by saying I
am a Muslim, you don't go to Jenna. I
said in my talk, Allah says in surah
Ankabud chapter 29 verse number two,
just by saying you believe, just by
saying I am a M, I am a Muslim, do you
think you'll go to Jenna? Allah will
surely test you. So just by saying I am
a Muslim, you will not go to Jenna. A
person who practices Islam, Islam comes
from the root towards salam which means
peace. It also means submitting a will
to God. A person who submits a will to
God is called a Muslim. So a person who
follows the religion or submitting his
will to almighty God is a Muslim. So
anyone who submits his will to Almighty
God. Whatever his name may be, he will
go to Jenna. So criteria to go to Jenna
is having iman. In all the pillars I
mentioned, Almighty God is there. You
have messengers about the hereafter
about his books etc. doing righteous
deed and submitting a will to almighty
god. If you submit a will to almighty
god in Arabic it is called as religion
of Islam. But it doesn't mean that if
you live in Pakistan or live in Saudi
Arabia go to Jenna. No all the people in
Saudi Arabia all in Pakistan Allaham
Allah alone knows whether they go to
Jenna or not. The person who go to
paradise brother is one who obeys the
commandment of almighty god. The person
who obeys the commandment of almighty
god and I discussed many in my talk. If
you obey these commandments of almighty
god just by name calling yourself Muslim
or Muhammad Abdullah that will not take
you to Jenna. It is not compulsory to
change your name. The name green is not
a Muslim name. So that doesn't mean you
won't go to Jenna. We prayed that the
brother inshallah he has reverted. He
was a Christian. So the name will not
take you to Jenna. Your deeds will take
you believing your deeds exorting people
to truth and exorting people to patience
and pment. If your deeds are right, if I
iman is right and you exalt people to
truth and patient purs
new college
and my views are so controversial to
him. So but it is my duty to put my
question. He has said that Krishna has
married to 16,000 wives and why can't a
Muslim to marry four or five wives.
This shows that you two religions are
united in suppressing the human rights.
You have said that you you may say that
women's women are so attractive but this
is a personal perspective.
And if you find so your your views are
corrupted and your mind is corrupted.
The concept of beauty is itself is also
changing. Once Cleopetra was beautiful
but it is not. So now is Roy ranks first
and you are you are also suggested for
the original text but it creates only
the phonetics and fundamentals when you
are convinced to a particular religious
ideology you find no wrong in the in
your crimes that is why that is the
thing which happened in Gujarat where
2,000 Muslims are murdered in the
streets no guard has come only
communists and some democrats efforts
were There people are announcing all the
religious values and for you like
persons that
uh it has come to a shock values
religion is failed and not the people.
So please allow the people to free and
allow them to join their social
movements like communist and axel
movements that the brother I believe is
a communist. He's asked a very good
question. He's saying that if Hinduism
allows and Krishna has married 16,18
wives and Islam allows. So Hinduism
Islam is joining in suppressing the
woman. According to you, according to
him, brother, he's saying Cleopatra was
beautiful today. She's not. Ashwarai is
number one for you, not for me.
So what is beautiful for you may not be
beautiful for me. I do agree with you.
It is a perspective. I do agree with
you. pressure I may be number one for
you not for me.
So we realize brother the concept of
difference changes and I gave the
example what is modest in America is not
modest here what is modest here is not
moder America who's to decide I do agree
with you if you think that marrying more
than one wife is suppressing the women
who's going to take care of the millions
of women you will take care will your
communist movement take care in the
glorious Quran gives you the solution to
the problems of humankind the solution
doesn't go down your throat I'm asking a
question today there are millions
Millions of millions of women more than
men who's going to take care of them who
even if you give them charity every
month that charity will not be
sufficient see man and woman have been
made sexual by nature Allah says in the
Quran in surah room chapter number 30
verse 21 yes put love and mercy between
their hearts I am a medical doctor I am
a medical doctor a woman cannot remain
virgin throughout her life cannot it's
not possible what are they going to do
what will happen they go to prostitution
what will a communism do for them what
the solution no solution solution. Allah
gives the solution of a creator. The
solution doesn't go down the throat. So
the problem is brother that solution is
that you give a better solution. Can you
think of a better solution? In Islam,
it's not compulsory to marry more than
one wife. It's not compulsory to marry
four. I don't know of a single Indian
Muslim who has got four wives. I don't
know of any. There are other foreigners
Muslim who have got. You have to realize
brother this is the solution. Everyone
cannot marry more than one woman.
Everyone cannot. But certain men who can
do justice between the wives, Allah has
given them permission. If they can do
justice, what is troubling? You have to
understand where are we suppressing
them. We uplifting them. The so-called
modernity you're talking about in
America in the name of art and culture.
What are they doing? They're degrading
the women. Your talk of women's
liberalization is nothing but it is an
exploitation of a body, degradation of
honor and deprivation of a soul. The
western society claiming to uplift the
woman have actually degraded her to a
concubine to a mistresses and society
butterflies which are hidden behind the
colorful skin of art and culture. In the
name of art and culture and what is that
modeling is it right? So the problem is
brother you have to put your thinking
right is important. We don't want to
sell our daughters. We don't want to
sell our mothers. If you want you can do
it. And the famous ad I'm told which I
gave the example last time of the BMW.
Someone told me very famous ad. No BMW
car. It is a very famous car. Youngsters
go in competition in Mercedes. In the
ad, there's a woman standing in a bikini
in front of the ad. Test driver now. Who
the girl or the car?
What are you doing? In the name of
communism, in the name of uplifting
women, you're selling your daughters.
You're selling your mothers. We Muslims
don't want to do it. We don't want to do
it.
In America, in America, you can have
mistresses 5, 10, 20. No one can stop
you. So in communism having mistress is
allowed. Having more than one wife you
have to give her rights. You cannot
treat her. You have to give her honor.
You have to give your property. That
doesn't go down your throat. Who is
degrading the woman? You or me? You know
in America one of the most advanced
countries. These American who talk about
that Islam degrades the woman. Do you
know out of those people accepting Islam
today Islam is the fastest growing
religion. Out of those people accepting
Islam
twoth3 of the people are women. If Islam
degrades the woman, then why are the
American women accepting Islam? Why are
the American men accepting Islam?
Who falls Dr. Abuham to accept Islam?
Who force brother Abdulin to accept
Islam? Who? If you see the women,
twothird of the people are women. They
accepting Islam. Why? If Islam degrades
the woman, why will they accept Islam?
Because they know that Islam gives
security to the woman. Islam uplits
women. That security may not go with
your purpose of making money in art and
culture. Like the politicians, they want
to divide and rule. These people of art
and culture talking about uplifting the
women, beauty context, they're selling
cosmetics. They make billions of
dollars. You know that the beauty
contest for what? In the name of beauty
context, they're making billions of
dollars. So just because they want to
make billions of dollars, all of many of
the women want to go and see. So if you
realize brother, we don't believe in
exhibiting off women in front of public.
We respect them. We love them. And we
rever them. We don't degrade them.
[Applause]
We have a non-Muslim sister. Yeah. Uh
the the answer that you gave me, your
logic and statistics made me think for a
while. Uh but I still have a point to be
clear. Probably in I mean at a previous
point of time in those days, men had to
go to the battlefield. The only source
of income for a family was through men.
But now times are changing and probably
in the future times will still more
change and women might go to the
battlefield and women and right now
women are are going for for for jobs and
probably the mortality rate for women
might increase too. At that point of
time is it okay to modify and say that
there can be just one wife for for a
man. After all religion is for mortal
creatures like us and not for not for
God. Sister asked a very good question.
At that time in wars maybe men were
dying more. I agree with her. Now the
times of wars have changed but even
today sister in the war was wars more
men are dying in the Gulf War more men
died in the Afghanistan war more men
died in Vietnam war more men died but
the percentage was much less as compared
to the older I do agree with you today I
gave the statisticy more people are
dying of cigarette smoking they are men
rather than women more people dying of
alcoholism more men than women accident
more men than women I do agree with you
that now women started going to the
battlefield and in America when I was
there in USA just a few years back they
started a woman section women going and
there's a big section of women joining
the military do you know the president
of America that time it was Bill Clinton
I think Bill Clinton he had to apologize
in the parliament you know 96 women were
raped by the superior
he had to apologize in the parliament
majority of the women that take part in
this battlefield they are raped by the
superior when you have
shoulderto-shoulder going to war what
will happen
see this is statistics sister this is
statistics of America the problem I do
agree with you sister I do agree with
your question your question are innocent
because you don't know the statistics do
you know the statistics I do agree women
are going for job in America do you know
in America every day according to the
statistics of 1996 US department of
justice 2713
women are being raped every day every 32
seconds one woman is being raped we are
here in this order for the past 3 hours
for the past 3 hours more than 300 women
may have been raped in USA until the
time I'm here.
Why?
Islam is not against women working.
Islam is not against women working but
is the duty of the man to be the bed
earner. They can work but it should be a
modest work. It should not be modeling,
dancing, singing or intermingling with
the gents working is allowed sister but
if you do those works which are immodest
there are high chances that you may be
degraded. There may be immorality. Yes
sister you have some comments. uh I'm
not talking about any uh I mean
degrading uh the modesty of a woman kind
of jobs. I'm talking about modest jobs
say driving itself there are the the the
number of women drivers in the world are
increasing what at one point of time
let's say of a hypothetical situation at
one point of time the number of women
drivers in the world increase and the
mortality rate of a woman increase at
that point of time is it okay for us to
accept a religion and say that a man can
have just one I'm not just talking about
this particular aspect of of any
religion alone any any aspect of
religion is it okay to modify religion
as as times are changing we still have a
good question that can we modify
religion as times are changing. If the
religion is not perfect, it requires a
modification. If the religion is
perfect, no modification is required.
So if the religion has a problem,
therefore I told you point out a single
fault. You're talking hypothetically.
Hypothetically after 100 years if women
starts diving if women die if women
population becomes less if if if sister
our creator almighty god knows the
future you and I don't know
he knows the future he said a man is
permitted to have more than one wife not
compulsory even if I agree with you even
if I agree with the woman population
becomes same it's not compulsory for a
Muslim to have more than one wife I have
got only one wife Here
I've got one wife only and I'm satisfied
with her. I don't intend marrying more.
There's no problem. If someone can do
there's no problem at all. Want to marry
marry? Don't want to mar don't marry.
But if you marry you should do justice
between a wife. So sister our almighty
god creator he knows about the future.
Suppose doctor says don't have sinide
but if the site doesn't harm me and if I
have it hypothetical the doctor knows
but a doctor is a human being can make
mistake almighty god is the biggest
doctor of everything he's the biggest
doctor he knows what is required for
therefore I said point out a mistake now
tomorrow there may be something then
inshallah you can come and ask me the
question tomorrow and then I'll give you
the reply
may we have the next question from the
brother at the back
my name isan I'm doing I'm an
engineering graduate. Um I would like to
pose a question. Uh you said that Das
had three wives and we know that in
Ramayana Das did an attempt to give
equality to all the three wives he lost
his life. Do you can say this as a test
of test by inshallah but is this test
suitable for the wives? Because they are
being suffered. Who is going to take
care of the wives if the person is not
is failing in the test? What will be the
question of those people? Is this
correct? The brother asked a question
that Gindashad had more than one wife
while the equality of the wives the
woman suffered. That's what he's saying.
So that's a test. The Quran says
suffering is a test. So when I studied
when I studied for MBBS exam and I
slogged out I used to slog out. Believe
me even if you give me a million rupees
I would never like to appear for my
medical examination again. I slogged out
for the degree. So all the suffering it
is a test. It is a test. So here we
realize that's a test for her. If she
behaves like a good wife, that woman and
follows the commandments of almighty
God, does the duty of a wife, even if
the husband does or not, she will pass
the test. The husband may fail the test.
So this life brother is a small portion.
An average human being lives for about
50 years or 40 years. Some at the age of
20, some at the age of 80, average about
40 to 60 years a human being lives. But
this life compared to next life is 0
very small percentage. So if I tell you
that in this small percentage compared
to next life I'll give you pain and next
life whatever you want you'll get.
You'll say I don't mind you do what we
want give me pain next life I will get
what I want. So good businessman will
say I don't mind trouble and pain like
before the examination we slog out we
don't sleep also why because we want to
pass the examination. Similarly if the
wife underos certain trials and
tribulation whatever it is if she
follows the command of almighty god in
the Quran she will go to paradise. If
the husband doesn't follow, he will not
go to paradise. If he follows, he'll go
to paradise. Hope that answers the
question. The next question from brother
at my right. I'm here again brother.
Some people call the religious people
call God by his name and some other call
this superpower
and uh scientists say cosmic energy and
parasychology it says superconscience.
So super conscience that this
parasychology subject itself proves that
God is existing. It is always there.
Brother can you please uh what I'm
trying to what I'm trying to say is can
you please repeat your question slowly?
Yeah.
Somebody see people call God according
to their knowledge the level of
knowledge right see somebody call super
conscience some people say super power
supreme being and all that. So let me
take the term sup uh cosmic energy. the
energy which existed from the beginning
and which created the world according to
the scientists I'm talking to you
because
you know this some people say it's a
fabricated one it was fabricated by the
Roman emperor Constantinople
in AD 325 in Nessiah conference they
fabricated the teachings
and in that they say God rested on the
seventh day I don't want to mention the
religion's
And if the cosmic energy is going to
rest suddenly everything will collapse
within few moments and I would like to
know what this cosmic energy was doing
before the creation and right from the
creation till the end of the human race
and what is it going to do after this
after the existing of this existence of
this world. Thank you. I think the
speaker has got the whether there was a
question that some people call
superconscious, some people call super
power, some people call cosmic energy.
Whether whatever name you give it should
be correct name. If it is a wrong name,
we don't accept it. Some people give a
correct name superpower, no problem.
Super being, no problem. Certain names
may be correct, certain name may not be
correct. One of the names you say is the
scientists say cosmic energy. And one of
the religions said almighty God rested
on the seventh day. We're giving a
quotation from the Bible. Book of
Genesis chapter number two verse number
two. Almighty God rested on the seventh
day. So if cosmic energy rest whole
system will collapse. I agree with you.
So we disagree with that scripture. And
regarding calling God cosmic energy, I
don't agree. God is the creator of the
energy of the universe. He is not cosmic
energy. He's more superior than that. He
created everything and everything is
dependent on him. So as far as the
religious scripture who says God rested,
we don't agree. God doesn't require
rest. Allah says in the Quran inal kuri
chapter number two verse 255 that Allah
does not require to sleep it does not
require to rest. So almighty god does
not require rest. This definition of
almighty god is wrong. The right
definition if you read in the Quran he
said doesn't require rest. And if you
give any name which is correct attribute
we have no objection. If you give the
wrong attributes there's a problem.
Today scientists are not eliminating god
they're eliminating models of god. Hope
that answers the question.
I would request our non-Muslim brothers
and sisters to please come up and stand
near the mic so that we are able to
identify and give you a chance to pose
the question. Yes. My name is Kali
Salvan. Mr. Sorry Dr. Al already said
the last messenger is
lost last messenger is Muhammad Navi. I
heard through my friend that uh Jesus
Christ come again.
Is it true or not?
There was a question that prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
the last nabi last prophet but one of
his friends said Jesus Christ is going
to come again. Yes, that is mentioned in
the Bible also Jesus Christ peace will
come again. It's even mentioned the
various verses in the Quran including
surah Maida chapter number 5 verse
number 116 and there are no less than 70
say hadith mentioning about Jesus Christ
peace come. But the reason why Jesus
Christ peace be upon him come again is
because Jesus Christ peace be upon him
was the only messenger of almighty God
whose follower as a whole they mistook
him that he claimed divinity. There's no
other messenger whose followers as a
whole. They mistook that he claimed
divinity. But the Christians, most of
them, they mistook that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him. He claimed divinity.
So that's the reason Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala raised him up alive. He'll come
in his second coming as Allah says in
the Quran in surah maida chapter number
5 verse number 116. On that day you be
my witness. Ya Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala. Oh God, I never told them to
worship me but I saidd
worship Allah
my lord and your lord. So in his second
coming he will come to testify that I
never told you to worship me but I told
you to worship only one god. So when his
second coming he will not bring a new
law. He will come as um of Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. He will
follow the same law of the Quran and the
hadith. He will not teach anything new.
He will come to testify only to the
Christians that I never claim divinity
and he will follow the law of the Quran
and the Sah. You said he's the final
messenger is again that Jesus Christ
will become law and the second coming he
will not get any new message. Messenger
means to get a message. He will not come
as a rasool. He will come to testify to
the Christians and never claim divinity.
He will not get a new message. The
message that he got the Injil was there
about 2,000 years back that has been
corrupted. Now Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam came. So even prophet
Jesus peace be upon him when he comes
back he will follow the message of the
Quran and the message of prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam. So
as a messenger in following the message
the last is prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. Hope that answer the question.
We have the next question from the
sister's side.
I'm Sha a software engineer. I embraced
Islam at the time of my marriage. I just
have only one question which relates to
humanity. Our topic is about peace to
humanity. Does Islam or in anywhere in
Quran is it specified about the woman
organ donation? If it is so is it
allowed or like why is the reason that
it is not allowed? So as I heard from
some of my friends
as a question that is there any mention
in the Quran that organ donation can be
done or not? There's no verse in the
Quran or any authentic hadith organ
transplantation organ donation can be
done or cannot done. But all the
scholars have got together and there are
several conferences taking place in
Mecca, in Riyad, in Malaysia. And the
scholarsly agree that organ donation and
organ transplantation can be done if
three criteria are fulfilled. Number
one, the person donating the organ, it
should not cause a major loss to his
health. I can't give my heart. If I
donate my heart, I will die.
But doctors say that I've got two
kidneys, one kidney sufficient. And if
my mother both her kidneys have failed,
I can give a kidney to her. even she
will survive and even I will survive. So
point number one, the person donating
the organ should not cause a major loss
to his health. Point number two, the
person receiving the organ should be a
major benefit for his health. Point
number three, it should not be for money
for economic reasons. Person can't sell
his kidney. So if these three things are
fulfilled, the scholars say under these
conditions, organ donation can be done,
organ transplantation can be done. Hope
that answers the question. Please pose
your question. Yeah, my name is Amish. I
got a question.
What do you think why God created us? Do
you think he created us to send here for
test in order to categorize us for
heaven or hell?
Well, as the question why did God create
us? And on the second day of this
conference, I gave a talk on purpose of
creation for about 1 hour 15 minutes. I
don't intend to be the lecture. One of
the reasons is that God created us for
the test.
The hereafter this life as Quran says
inah chapter number 16 verse number two
he has created death and life to test
which of us in good deeds and besides
that one of his unique creation is he
created the human beings who have a free
will. We can either obey almighty God or
we may disobey almighty god. We have
been given the free will and almighty
god asked us before we came in this
world who would like to become a human
being. So we opted for that. You and I
in the previous life before we came in
this world we opted for that. So based
on that almighty God gave us a free
will. Now after we get free will we
either have the option to obey God or
disobey God. If we obey God we get ja.
If we disobey God then we don't get ja.
So this life is a test for the
hereafter. Other creations angels don't
have a free will. They always obey Allah
subhana wa tala. So we opted for the
test. We opted for the test. So we
undergoing the test. So based on this
test
we will get our reward and punishment.
Allah says in the Quran in surah dar
50:56 Allah says
that we have created jin and the men not
but to worship me. So one of the reasons
for our creation is worship and there's
a test for the hereafter. Allah
subhananaa tala does not require us to
worship him. Whether we worship him or
not he is yet great. It will not
diminish him. It will not make him
superior. We are undergoing the test for
our benefit. We opted it is like I opted
to appear for the medical examination. I
opted. So the teacher she corrected okay
fine and I passed the test. So similarly
brother we opted and we undergoing the
test and for the complete answer you can
refer to my video said the purpose of
creation.
Yes brother can we have the next
question from you.
Respected sir
I have four questions.
First one is brother to believe please
mention your name and one question at a
time. Shigil
uh there are some uh hard to believe
instances in any scriptures for instance
uh in Quran like birds dropping stones
in a uh battlefield on the enemy's uh uh
context like that uh which is hard to
believe.
That's my first question.
There's a question there are certain
things mentioned in the Quran like birds
dropping stones talking about surah
surah chapter number 105 there are many
things for example Quran says about
shakar prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam split the moon into two musam
split the sea into two these are
difficult things yes these are known as
miracles miracles are those thing which
a human mind cannot conceive how it
happened for us human being
to make the moon into two is not
possible. First human being to split the
sea into two and have a pathway not
possible. So these are known as miracles
which only god can do you and I cannot
do. So it's difficult for us to
conceive. The only way for us to testify
is to go back into time. You're sitting
now. We can't go back
3,000 4,000 years back and check up
whether Musa Alisam Moses did he split
the sea or not. So what we say these are
miracles which doesn't allow us to go
back in time. But there are many things
which Quran has said which has come to
today. For example, Quran speaks about
science about the big bang. Quran speaks
the light of the moon not its own light.
Quran speak the earth is spherical.
Quran speak the sun rotates. Which to a
man 4900 years back would sound what is
this nonsense that the moon has its own
light. That the earth is spherical. All
these things about the big bang. But
today after science has advanced we have
come to know it's a fact. But to know
what happened in the past we can't go
back in time. So what my logic says
whatever the Quran has mentioned certain
things we can check up now. Certain
things we can't check up. We can't go
back in time. So that goes with
ambiguous lot. So what things we can
check up today? Out of those things
whatever we can check up 80% things we
can check up. So my logic says 80% of
what the Quran mentioned we can check up
today and we have come to 100% correct.
Whatever we can check not even 1% is
wrong. Most of the countries are
historic. I think so. Yes. That's what
I'm telling you brother. Historic for
you to say that thing didn't happen. You
can only prove by going back in time. If
the Quran says prophet Moses split the
sea you can't prove that he didn't
split. Neither can you prove he split.
But we can't go back in time. Can we go
back 3,000 4,000 years back? Can we go?
We can't. So what we say logically this
may have happened, may not have
happened. May have happened, may not
have happened. The birds may have
dropped stone, may not have dropped
stone. Correct? What we say this is
ambiguous. If we talk about the nuclear
bomb thousand years back, would they
have believed? Would they have believed?
They would have said this is nonsense.
Right or wrong? But today you and I
believe or not because science will
advance. Similarly, there's nuclear
bomb, there's atom bomb. So birds
dropping stones. What's the problem? It
is so easy. Nuclear bomb is more
difficult. So here we realize we cannot
go back in time. So what my logic says
whatever we can testify today, whatever
we can analyze today, out of that 100%
has been proved to be correct. 20% we
can't analyze. We cannot go back. We
can't go in future. We cannot prove
scientifically whether there's heaven or
hell. So you'll ask me brother Zakir,
you're a medical doctor. How do you
believe in heaven and hell? I said that
goes in the 20% ambiguous lot. So my
logic says when 80%
what we can check today of the Quran has
been 100% to be correct not even.1% is
wrong. So my logic says what 20% is
ambiguous inshallah God willing even
that will be correct. Maybe science will
advance after 50 years after 20 years
we'll come to know about life after
death. We may come to know about heaven
or hell. So my logic says it's a logical
belief that when not even 0001% has been
proved wrong of the Quran 80% is 100%
correct. So my logic says inshallah the
20% which you can't verify by going back
in time or going in future even that
inshallah I'll be correct. Hope that
answers the question. May we have the
next question for brother here.
Hello I'm Ashoke here. I'm doing my MA
economics in Loyala College. So my
question is that in this time of in this
time of this like uh every world is in a
very distress we are in a way of we want
peace whether there is a region whether
is a religion peace or whatever it is we
need peace we need some humanity
and we have lots of people from outside
countries also. So is the religion is
the sole thing that we are doing so much
of problems all around. Is the religion
is the sole problem for that we are
demolishing the WTO all around and we
have lots of problem over there and is
is the religion is the solution for the
things happening all around the world
and is it the solution for the people
dying in Ethiopia? We have children
dying out of hunger is the solution is
the religion solution for them. What is
the solution for the real thing for what
we are wondering all around is it the
religion is the only solution for what
we are debating all this time what I
think so we need solution for that
that's a good question that we having so
many problem in the world is religion
the solution for this problem there are
so many people dying in Ethiopia is
religion the solution brother the
religion which is true is the solution
Allah says in the Quran in surah alah
Iran chapter number 3 verse number 19 in
the al- Islam the only religion
acceptable in The sight of almighty god
is submitting a will to almighty god. If
every human being submits a will to
almighty god you won't have a problem
inia. Allah says in the Quran and
several say hadith that the third pillar
of Islam is every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level 85
grams of gold should give 2.5% of his
saving in charity. If every rich human
being gives charity poverty will be
eradicated from this world. Leave us at
ethopia there will not be a single human
being anywhere in the world who will die
of hunger.
Do you know that the three richest men
in the world, the three richest men in
the world, their wealth is equal to 48
poorest country's GDP, three richest
men, if all of these people give zakat,
it will solve the problem of the
humankind. So the problem is that if
every human being follows follows the
religion of submitting his will to
almighty god like that you gave one
problem. Any problem you get,
alhamdulillah, the glorious Quran has
the solution to the problem. Follow the
right religion and you'll get real
peace.
Do we have a question from the sister's
side? Yeah, there's a question from the
non-Muslim sister.
[Music]
When a Muslim is in a non-Muslim's house
at the time of prayer, at the time of
salah, can he or she do his prayer in
their house or what is the right way to
do it? And can a Muslim take prasad
from the temples?
There are two question. Number one is
can a Muslim pray in the house of a
non-Muslim as long as there's nothing
which is wrong in the house as long
there's no idol in the front. As long
the place you're praying is a clean
place. You can pray any part of the
world. Our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said it's mentioned in
Bkari number one in the book of Salah
that the whole world is a mosque for the
believers. So as long as the place is
clean
and doesn't break any rules of the
Sharia, there's no idol in front. You
can very well pray regarding taking
prasad. Prasad is a food which is given
by the Hindus in the name of dietes and
gods. Allah says in the Quran in no less
than four different play in surah bakar
chapter number 2 verse number 173 in
surah maida chapter number 5 verse
number three in surah nam chapter number
6 verse number 145 and surah chapter
number 16 verse number 115
forbidden for you for food are dead meat
blood the flesh of swine and any food on
which any name besides Allah's name is
taken so eating prasad is haram it's not
permitted in Islam but we know many
Muslims you know we don't want to offend
We don't want to offend our non-Muslims.
So what they do some of the Muslims they
say bismillah and have it.
So tomorrow you'll say bismillah and
have alcohol after that say and have
poke. Eating any food on which any name
besides Allah name is taken is in Islam.
How to deal with them? You can refer to
my video cassette dawa or distraction
which shows you a way how to convince a
non-Muslim regarding the concept of
prasad and how to convince them through
their scriptures about the true concept.
Hope that answers the question. Next
question from the brother at the back.
Yes. Um I want to make one thing clear.
Is everything test of Allah?
Is everything a test of Allah?
Has a question that is everything a test
of Allah? This life is a test. Sometimes
we are self-care problem for us. We are
self-care problems for us. So this life
brother is a test for the hereafter.
Say that nobody reaches heaven because
to humane.
The brother said that if that's the case
then nobody reaches heaven because it is
human to her and I agree with you
brother. I agree with you totally. It is
human to earth. Everyone will make a
mistake. That the reason a beloved
prophet said and I mentioned in my talk
on the second day that no one can enter
Jenna without the grace and the mercy of
Allah subhana wa t'ala. I said that in
my talk that we human being make mistake
but Allah is forgiving. He is kafur. He
is raheem. He's merciful. He's
beneficial. And he forgives his people.
But even he has rules and regulations.
Even he himself doesn't just say, "Okay,
fine. You look good. I forgive you. You
don't look good. I don't forgive you."
He has got his rules and regulations for
the human being mentioned in the Quran.
So you can only go to Jenna with the
mercy of Almighty God. If Almighty God
catches every mistake of yours and gives
you a negative point and gives you a
positive point for all the good deeds
that you do, then no human being will
enter Jenna. not have been prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
himself. That's what the prophet said.
It's a hadith of the prophet. It's
mentioned in the Quran that Allah will
multiply your good deeds by 10 times.
But a wrong thing will only count as
one. So because of this mercy of
almighty God, he forgives many of his
mistakes. The only thing which will not
forgive. It's mentioned in the Quran in
surah Nisa chapter number 4:48 and surah
Nisa chapter 4 116 that the sin which
Allah will never forgive is the sin of
shik associating partner with almighty
god. any other sin if he wants he may
forgive you because associating partner
with almighty god is a sin which is the
biggest of them. Hope that answers the
question.
Do you have a counter question brother?
Yeah. Then you mean to say that a person
who is doing all good deeds and making
an error in having three boys but not
treating them equally will it be uh he
will he be attaining heaven?
A question if I understood your question
that if a person if he has three wives
and doesn't treat all his wives equally
can he go to Jenna he can go why not
because see for us to be absolutely pure
you yourself said it is human to earth
with all the good thing something evil
thought may come in your mind even
that's wrong so if you make mistakes you
ask for forgiveness a person who doesn't
treat his three wives equally if he asks
for forgiveness Allah may forgive Allah
put him in Jenna his other good deeds
may be so much that Allah will forgive
this so that depends on Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala who's the master of day of
judgment a person should treat his wife
equally but if he doesn't treat he may
go to Jenna may not go depending upon
all his full life put together Allah is
the master of day of judgment he may go
he may not go if he asks for forgiveness
Allah may forgive him hope that answers
the question
uh we'll take this yes brother you
Sir, what are the halal or allowed means
of entertainment in Islam? What about
the role of music? And
what about Sufi vision of Islam? Does it
come inside the framework or is it
outside? Brother, what are the halal
ways of entertainment? Entertainment is
your perception. Was entertainment for
you may not be entertainment for me.
Like people today are being entertained.
They're getting knowledge and
entertainment. This is halal.
So the halal way of entertainment are
those entertainment which doesn't go
against the Quran and the Sunnah. What
is mentioned haram in the Quran they say
hadith if you abstain from that all the
other ways are halal as far as music is
concerned had of prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam that music is not
permitted except for duff except for the
duff one-sided open drum all the other
music is not permitted because it takes
you away from Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
takes you away from him with Allah
subhanaa that is the reason it has been
prohibited and your third question was
the Sufi thing of Islam Sufi is an
Arabic word come from Suf it is again
more of a deviation in my earlier runs I
told you the right concept is following
Quran and the sunnah so if you follow
anything which is not mentioned in the
Quran the sunnah and say it's part of
dean then it's a deviation most of this
is a deviation that you have of the
sufism it's more of a deviation it's not
the right Islam is following Quran and
the sunnah any scholar says anything let
any scholar you have to go and seen the
Quran and sunnah any other source the
right source is Quran and the most
authentic English translation most
authentic in your in your opinion most
authentic English translation brother
the Arabic is the word of God is 100%
without any error all the translations
are human work and they're bound to have
errors so they cannot be error-free
translation yes but amongst the
translations available the good one that
I feel one of them is the sai
international the English translation
I'm talking about other languages you
can ask the local people in English one
of the good translation I is the Sai
International which has been translated
by three ladies who originally
American the westerners they were and
they accepted Islam say international
the copy which I gave to the brother
earlier and if you want I would like to
give you also inshallah after the talk
you can contact brother Ashraf he will
give you a copy of the s international
and you can read the translation hope
that's the question you're most welcome
okay we have a non-Muslim brother at
that mic uh can we have the question
from you yes good evening my name is
Shri I'm a Hindu
uh without practicing uh Islam do you
mean to say it is difficult by
practicing Christianity or by Hinduism
to go attain the uh paradise after
death?
That's a very good question that without
practicing Islam can you practice
Krishna and Hinduism can you go to
paradise or you cannot go to paradise
brother as I said the Quran says inah
Imran chapter 3 verse number 19 in Islam
the only religion acceptable to almighty
god is submitting to almighty god if you
read Christianity the word Christianity
is not there in the whole bible like how
hinduism is not there in the Hindu
scripture the word Christianity doesn't
exist it's not there in the bible the
word Christian was used first time in
the book of acts
by the people to describe the follow of
Jesus Christ peace be upon him. It was a
nickname by the people given of Antioch
in the book of Acts. If you read
Christian, the word Christianity is not
there in the Bible. So Jesus Christ
peace be upon him preached nothing but
Islam.
Therefore, he's going to come in the
second coming to testify there nothing
like Christianity.
Abraham peace be upon him, Quran says
inah Imran 3:67, he was not a Jew or a
Christian. He was a Muslim. Abraham
peace be upon him taught Islam. Moses
peace taught Islam. Again, Islam don't
think Islam is okay fine. I have to have
a Muslim name. I have to live in Arab
country. after our zakir name Abdul.
Islam means submitting a will to
almighty god. If you submit a will to
almighty god or a muslim Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said it's mentioned in
the gospel of John chapter number 5
verse number 30. I can of my own self do
nothing. As I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will
but the will of almighty god. Anyone who
says that I follow not my will the will
of almighty god he's a Muslim. So Jesus
Christ peace be a muslim. He preached
Islam. I've given the talk on
similarities between Islam and
Christianity. And I've proved that even
in Christianity. They say believe in one
God. Don't believe in divinity. Don't
make images of almighty God. God is not
begotten. All from the Bible. From the
Bible has proved how to offer salah.
From the Bible about zakat, about Hajj,
should not have alcohol, about modesty.
From the Bible. So even Jesus Christ
peace be upon him. He did not come to
preach Christianity. He came to preach
Islam. And almighty God is the same God
for all the human beings. He has only
given one religion. No other religion.
All these are corrupted form of the
original religion. Like how the brother
said Sufiism even that's a corrupted
form of Islam. It is not Islam at all.
What we have to follow is true Islam.
The Quran and the Sahad and all the
messengers they taught only Islam. So if
you follow Jesus Christ peace be upon
him by going to the scriptures. Jesus
Christ never said worship me. He never
claimed divinity.
In fact, there's not a single antiqu
statement in the complete Bible where
Jesus Christ peace be upon himself says
that he's God or where he says worship
me. But the Christian says you cannot
enter paradise until you believe Jesus
Christ died for your sin. He was
almighty God. There's not a single
unequivocal statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that he's God or where he
says worship me. If any Christian can
show me any statement in the Bible where
Jesus Christ peace be upon himself says
that I am God or where he says worship
me I'm ready to accept Christianity
today.
In fact Jesus Christ peace be upon said
it's mentioned in the gospel of John
chapter number 14 verse number 28 he
said my father is greater than I. Gospel
of John chapter number 10 verse number
29 my father is greater than all. Gospel
of Matthew chapter number 12 verse
number 28 I with the spirit of God I
cast out devil. Gospel of Luke chapter
number 11 verse number 20 I with the
finger of God cast out devil. Gospel of
John chapter number 5 verse number 30. I
can of my own self do nothing. As I hear
I judge and my judgment is just for I
seek not my will but the will of my
father. He submitted his will to
almighty God. He was a Muslim. It's
clearly mentioned in the book of Acts
chapter number two verse number 22. He
said a man of Israel listen to this.
Jesus of Nazareth a man approved of God
amongst you by wonders and miracles
which God did by him and you are witness
to it. A man approved of God amongst you
by wonders and miracles which God did by
him and you witness to it. So if you say
Christian means a person who follows the
teachings of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him then I say we Muslims are more
Christian than the Christians
themselves.
The Bible says don't have poke. Bible
says the woman should cover the head.
It's mentioned in the first Corinthians.
1 Corinthians chapter number 11 verse
number 5 to7. The woman does not cover
her head. A head should be shaved off.
So brother all the messengers of
almighty God they taught nothing but
Islam. Islam is submitting a will to
Almighty God. So if you submit a will to
Almighty God, you'll go to paradise. If
you don't submit, you will not go. Hope
that answers the question. We have time
for one last question. If you have a
non-Muslim brother, yes, you can ask
question. Uh respect us sir. My question
is can you please speak slowly and in
the mic so that we can hear the
question. I want to know your
description like you know I mean Quran's
description of heaven.
brother wants to know the Quran
description of heaven and I mentioned in
short heaven is a place it's not and
Jenna the translation of Jenna in Arabic
into English is garden it's talking
about bliss a place of bliss where it
gives a description that there will be
rivers flowing beneath your feet rivers
of honey rivers of milk talking about
fruits pomegranates etc this place is
your reward in the next life sir
respected sir yes you said you want the
description of Jenna uh Yes sir.
Respected sir. How will we be in heaven?
Like we'll be like normal human beings
or like the brother. I mean one more
thing sir like if you can't find heaven
here I don't think we'll be able to find
heaven anywhere. I mean honest opinion.
How will we be? How will we be? We'll be
the same brother here we require many
things. There it is different. We will
not be the same. There we'll be in a
different form. How will be Allah? We'll
be different. We won't have all these
evil thoughts coming. If you enter
Jenna, I'm not talking about ears like
eyes and nose and all our mind or our
soul as such. I mean as you described,
how will it be? That will come to
inshallah when we go to Jenna. So you
and I pray that we go to Jenna. Then
you're taking me to some place where
like you don't have any description. I
mean sorry you're taking me to some
place which you can't describe. As I
told you, you asked me the description.
I started giving the description. Then
you told me not of the place how I will
be. How will I be? Will I have a beard?
Will I be young? I'm talking I'm not
talking about beard or anything. I'm
talking about your your soul, your mind.
Our soul will be there. Allah says in
the Quran in 3:1 185
every soul shall taste that our soul
will be there. Our body will not be
there. Our soul is there will be there.
But how will we be resurrected? Like a
old woman who died at the age of 80. How
will she be resurrected? Young old Allah
alam it will be different. I mean I'm
not talking about the body. Okay. You're
talking about the soul. Soul will be
there. So you telling soul is
responsible for everything. Soul is
responsible for all this thing.
all these actions and all these things.
Brother, I mean how do you if I go to
heaven then I'll think about like okay
I'll have 17 virgins whom I can have sex
okay I can think of like okay fine
there'll be some other place better than
heaven I mean it'll be like going on I
mean how can how will it basically the
evils are due to man's desire I mean
that's right how how am I sure that
heaven I'll be I I'll be happy with the
same mind and soul that's what I told
you brother how will you be sure I told
you if this book there's something like
logic if I verified this book 80% of
these books I have verified to be 100%
correct remaining 20% is ambiguous
neither right neither wrong so I as a
person of logic and a medical doctor my
logic says when 80% is 100% correct 20%
is ambiguous ambiguous not known sir
like any any religious book is is is
difficult to refute I mean you take you
take whether you are saying it's
difficult to refute you can hear my
video cassettes you can hear my video
cassette I had a debate with Dr. William
Campbell in Chicago on the topic of
Quran and Bible and the right of
science. You see if I want I can refute
many books but today my job here is not
to refute to come to common terms. If I
want I can give a talk on the
differences in Hinduism. I can speak
about the scientific errors in Hinduism
in the Bible. My job is not that. What
I've done is a presentation on the
commonalities in Islam and Hinduism.
What I've spoken is the established
truth what is mentioned in the Vedas. I
picked it up and present it to the
people. If you agree with the Vedas you
follow. If you don't agree the choice is
yours. So even the Vedas speak about
swag, about nerk, about heaven and hell.
You like it, you accept it. Don't like
it, don't accept it. We'll come to know
on the day of judgment who's right.
Thank you very much, brothers and
sisters. Affair. Now I request brother
Green to make a vote of thanks. Brother
Green.
I would like to uh thank the people of
Chennai for coming for this marvelous uh
talk by uh Dr. Zak. We learned a lot
tonight. Alhamdulillah. And I hope that
we're all going to use this uh knowledge
for the benefit uh to inshallah let
other people know about this beautiful
religion of Islam. And we want would
also like to congratulate all the
brothers and sisters who parttook in
making this fantastic exhibition such a
great success. Alhamdulillah.
Thank you very much brothers and
sisters.